there are two major strategic approaches
to terraforming Mars This playthrough
will look at the first of these which is
the terraforming approach that rushes
The End Game and minimizes engine
building I'll be talking strategy with a
skilled Danish player boneless and will
analyze his choices in this game this is
legendary tactics
alright boneless tell me what you're
thinking for your corporation selection
and your Prelude cards here
yeah the cooperation I'm trusting Omni
uh today and the the preludes uh is
actually a big choice because I also had
the Prelude with the two titanium
production
and I if I remember I made a few
misplaced in this game this is like you
could you could count this as one of
them because I think it would be
slightly better to actually take the two
titanium production but the reason I did
what I did here yeah in the planetary
cinematics is I'm not so fond of this
cooperation I don't have a lot of
building Tech so yeah I'm gonna go home
I'm gonna go terraforming with a sound
so uh so this is going to be the the
rush strategy then you're gonna try to
close this game out quickly exactly and
so I'm I'm choosing the equifier here
and I'm not sure it's a it's a good
choice it's it makes a lot of sense of
course because uh I am trying to close
the game early and there's also this
hidden bonus that I believe I did the
math here and I I calculated that I
could play a nuclear Zone and I could
play a giant space mirror thanks to the
to Titanium I can get with the water and
the fact that I don't have to play five
Mega credits for the other Prelude so
there's a little bit of logic here but
everything being said and done I I
remember when I played this I felt all
right it was probably not the right
choice but you know I just want a
terraform today right okay now the
interplanetary cinematics you didn't
choose that Corporation but they they
get an extra 20 steal off the Hop so why
would you not go that way would that be
that's not as useful for this build uh I
think the only thing I have here steel
works with the building tag so that's
not really enough and I don't really
have a lot of events if I recall so
it didn't really make much sense and I
think the reason only is kind of strong
in this the uh the game is that I have
this uh um
steel uh oh God what's called I just
said it the one that works yeah still
works yeah yeah uh so so what I can do
is I can make four energy production in
the first generation
nice and then what I can do is I can use
steel works I can buy that in the second
generation so this means that I'll have
access to one free TR every generation
thanks to the steel works and this is
how I can just easily use only every
single generation oh so you're just
going to be cranking up the victory
points yeah yeah it's okay and you're
you're also going to rush the
terraforming rating because of the you
and me power
yes
for sure
um well what do you mean I mean only it
just gives me a flat TR the effect of
owning but but obviously to to get the
requirement for only I would have to be
terraforming so that's why it makes a
lot of sense to be terraforming a lot
with this Corporation right okay gotcha
yeah so for those of you who are joining
us I am very much a beginner and so the
the point of doing these videos today is
for boneless to teach me if you enjoy
board game strategy and you haven't
subscribed to our Channel yet please
consider stabbing the Subscribe button
now so wonderful okay so there's two
main strategies in the game we talked
about this in our strategy guide uh
we'll go over the what you call the
greedy strategy or the engine building
strategy in another video
um but one one thing you talked about
was if you want to slow a player down or
slow the end game down that you hold
back on one of the three end game
requirements well this this game's
already at Ford nine oceans
um so you know is there any way someone
could stop you from trying to rush this
game well first of all the ocean's not
going to be a problem because one of the
other guys already played aquafile
pumping so I've no doubt the ocean is
going to be close soon I'm not so
worried about the temperature either
because I I can at least do one TR every
generation with my steel works
um
so so it's about the Heat and when we
talk about the heat there's one card in
my opening hand I regret not getting it
gives me like one water and three heat
and then I go down to make acrylic
production
I'm not a big fan of this card in
general because it's a little bit rough
to start the game going down until you
make a credit production but right
looking back at it when this game is
it's a lot about the heat closing out uh
when when is that gonna happen so so
with this in mind I think maybe I should
have
hit this card but I think the reason I
did it is like this is because I I knew
that I I just calculated adjust barely
enough to to to play the cards I wanted
I want the steel works I wanted the
um nucleosone and I could only do this
if I didn't keep this card and if I
didn't keep this other Prelude but it's
it's kind of rough I I guess the um
I got one free uh heat production out of
the um nuclear zone so it's a it's a bit
of a tough choice maybe maybe it's not
so bad what I did but okay now tell me
about your thought process here I think
for as a new player it's overwhelming to
see you know there's over 200 cards in
the game or I don't know how many there
are tons and just seen all the possible
variations that's for you probably the
fun part because you know what they all
do you know the synergies but as a new
player how are you guiding what you
choose here
um okay so you you chose trees I think
there as and do you generally only just
choose one card uh or two cards or how
many do you buy because it costs three
uh major credits each right so what's
what's the balance there mathematically
I'm a bit greater if I'm going for the
long game I tend to keep more cards get
more card grow and stuff like this in
this game I'm just uh all right this is
a four player game um only I have I have
a lot of terraforming going I could
probably end the game pretty pretty
early so um I'm Not Gonna Keep so many
cards actually you'll see that I I might
even end up keeping a little bit too
many cards but we'll we'll get back to
that but the generally speaking what I
just want to close the game as soon as
possible it's it makes a lot of sense to
not the
buy so many cards okay the Subterranean
Reservoir yeah I mean I I don't really
have to because one guy has the water is
almost closed anyway so I think this is
one of the cards that I probably
shouldn't have bought I think I ended up
selling this once again that's okay I
killed farming that's that's the like
the best car I can get right now because
there's it's so early in the game and
there's already six water so this is
really good and here's another
questionable uh idea it's it's kind of
funny actually I I end up going for
physics complex here and the idea is
that I I I'm anticipating that the
oxygen is gonna be closed sooner rather
than later and then I'm gonna have like
already in my hand I have enough cards
to actually
fulfill the six energy that this physics
complex require so my idea is that I can
close the oxygen pretty soon I got the
Kilt farming and I got the steel works
and then after that I can get like maybe
two generations worth of physics complex
so that's like four points fix the
complex could give me so this is where
my head is at but the I'm not sure it's
a good idea because if I do if I don't
actually use six energy on uh one of
these science resources then this would
be six entity that gets transferred to
heat and yeah heat is gonna be the last
one to close so I'm not sure I made the
right call I think it's a little bit too
greedy okay well if anyone's played a
lot of terraforming Mars out there I'm
sure they'll let us know down in the
comments
yeah but it's uh sometimes you just want
to go all in on terraforming and this is
what I maybe should have done there but
also
um actually Jacob flexilios pointed this
out to me the other day that sometimes
it's also good to just do this uh his
go-to strategy is actually to do like a
middle middle road so he's going for
terraforming and he's going for some
cards but not too much card drawn then
he's like just want to close the game a
little bit uh before the greedy guys is
gonna overtake him so so his go-to
strategy is actually a little bit in the
middle of the road so uh just keep the
pressure on but uh give yourself time to
outperform everybody else with your
engine building in a small way
yeah I think I think this is what um
what I'm like going for here I'm still
getting a little bit of TR and as you
will see I also randomly picked up this
card in my hand that requires a jogian
tag so in order to actually get three
energy and three heat what's it called
being from a mass asteroid or something
right so it's a little bit awkward
because my thought was actually just to
go all in on terraforming just close the
game as soon as possible
um but the the cards I end up giving
getting is like
I'm kind of being not forced but I'm I'm
being inclined to actually go for a
little bit of terraforming as well or a
little bit of VP as well so for instance
now I kind of have to play another
jobian if I want to play this card
but maybe I'm not maybe I'm gonna sell
this car if I get some more energy
production another way so that's a lot
of things to consider to be honest it's
interesting The Invention contest only
two credits there uh for a player like
you that's fantastic because it gives
you three potential cards to improve
your draw with for me that's a nightmare
because I'm just like oh no what do I do
with these three cards
[Music]
yeah I don't know
um I think it's definitely
uh I I play a lot of greedy games so for
greedy games this is definitely a
perfect card for for it's it's still a
good card here but I I still think I'm
uh I'm keeping a little bit too many
cards here so here's also an interesting
one large Convoy
um I'm really thinking about keeping
this card because in the late game if I
can get like one animal card I can give
me a lot but here is actually uh a
jovian
that I'm thinking about getting methane
from Titan and once again it's a bit of
a bit counter intuitive to actually pick
up Joe games when you also just want a
terraforming Rush the game to an end as
soon as possible but here it makes sense
because well it does give me a little
bit it gives me like two heat to him to
play in production and also in it that
enables me to play the other driving
card because that one requires me to
actually play a job in card before I can
play this beam of from a thorum asteroid
so if people are pretty new to the game
can you explain what Jovian is uh
jovianist attack on this card for
example and usually it's a
when you think of Jovian text you think
of Jovian amplifiers which is like the
set collection of this game so there's
like four cards that says you get one
Victory Point per Jovian Tech you have
right so so in this case you can like
get a lot of points from Jovian tax
which is why this usually is something
you you kind of want to do uh for for if
you're playing the long read again
but in this case uh like I explained
that I had a little bit of of
ulterior motives
but uh I guess a game sorry go ahead no
no you I was just gonna say a game like
this where you're trying to rush it you
ideally want to close the game out
before anybody hits 100 points would
that be fair to say
yeah for sure
um I think I'm hoping uh for a 70
Russian game but I'm thinking uh because
of the heat I was it's a little bit
misleading because the heat was so high
to begin with but now that I look at the
other players it seems like nobody's
actually going for heat production right
so it's more realistic it's going to be
around a generation eight I would think
I can't remember but that would be my
guess okay notice actually a really
awkward turn because I think what's
Happening Here is I'm really playing for
this bonus
so I kind of already spent uh my mega
credit on this uh on this expensive
driving card and now I'm checking out
the other players to see how much plants
they have and how much gold they have
and I think one of the guys probably
green has a lot of plans so I kind of
don't want to actually use my action
because my action the steel Works
actually gives me one more um
oxygen so if I use this then he's
actually just going to get a free ticket
to get the bonus so I'm I'm slow pulling
a little bit here I'm selling some of
the the sort of questionable cards I I
picked up
and I think what also happened is this a
turn where I actually played this one
card we just talked about a mentioned
contest yes it is I just saw and then
locked there
and that was a mistake actually because
what happened is I I forgot about my
my Europa which is like get one TR for
three three Mega credits I had I hadn't
used that one yet so it's uh I could
still slow play I just had to sell a
little bit one more card and it would
have been fine but right here
okay so he's finally in a position where
he's I think he passed at this point
so um the good thing is I I forced him
to pass with a lot of plans if I I think
I look at greens sometimes here so now
he passed before me so now he's not
gonna get the bonus so and he didn't
want me to get the bonus either so we
actually passed with a lot of plans so
now there's a pretty high chance that I
can pick up this bonus in the Next
Generation it really depends on red
because red is going to start the next
Generation so there's actually a lot of
stuff going on here but the right here
mainly what I'm doing is I'm gonna spend
a lot of time here all right I I messed
up a little bit I really want to use
this Omni Corporation
um power here so do I really want to
sell three cards just so I can do that
and I think actually I I end up doing it
so uh
wow yeah that's a bit rough I really
noticed two major differences between
you as a more experienced player and me
I don't use the log very much and the
second element is just tracking what
everyone's doing and sort of knowing and
I guess it's because it's just it's such
a volume of information in this game
that as an early player I'm not ready to
take on not only my strategy but also
three other strategies and and how to
interact with that so um tell me about
the log um how are you using that here I
keep seeing you flashing over to that
um I'm just checking out what they're
doing to get an idea of what strategy
they're going for but mostly right here
I'm using it a lot to really keep track
on
um is someone like getting investment
loan I think a red plate just before or
something like this I want to see will
they get this bonus or am I in a good
position to get the bonus
um so so the bonus is the the main thing
right now um
for sure that must be a challenge to to
figure out if you're gonna beat them or
not because they may have some kind of
trick up their sleeve there must be
cards in there that allow them to
suddenly explode you know
yeah exactly so now I'm I am actually
selling three cards just so I can use
this power uh I didn't have to I just I
shouldn't have played invention contest
I should have just like sold one more
card and I would have been fine so that
was
it hurts a little bit but I think it's
the responsible thing to do it hurts a
little bit because I actually sold the
card that gives me two cards so this uh
this is like I would never do this if I
played a long game but but right here
when I'm trying to close the game early
I think it's it's something that I would
consider
yeah the temperature
um doesn't seem to be uh coming up very
quickly I thought it was gonna go a lot
quicker than this I started the same
mistake as you I was like ah the
temperature is probably fine but no no
it's just because a lot of people just
had a lot of like asteroids and like me
for example I had this nuclear Zone that
also gives two temperatures so we just
had a lot of those cards in the
beginning
and then it just stopped and which is
not what I want because I I have a
feeling that the one of the other guys
maybe two of them have a have a really
greedy money engine going on in this
game so this guy will beat me if the
game goes long so I like I can't allow
that so it's it's uh it's a little bit
the it's not in my interest that the
temperature stopped moving so uh so this
is why I'm also one of the reasons I'm
also going for these sort of sub-optimal
place of playing actually Jovian tags
and playing
the beam from a an asteroid that I have
in my hand so here's a big asteroid and
this is like kind of what I want but
this is me doing the math here and I
think that I only have enough money to
actually pick up one card because I also
want to play uh being from an asteroid
of stuff like this
um
in a quick game like this what would be
a typical income that you're happy with
you've got five right here is that yeah
this is fine normal yeah basically my my
main income comes from my TR right so
right here I have the 34 TR actually
left five so it's not great but it's not
bad either
um and then of course a big a big part
of my game is this free VP I can get
every single generation so I can get uh
or TR rather so I could get the actually
two TR right because I have the steel
works and I have the Omni so for three
Mega credits I can just get two tra
every generation that's like the biggest
strength of my build in this game I
think nice yeah and sometimes those they
add up over time those small advantages
yeah and it's actually yeah yeah uh you
were buying the imported ghg which is uh
he producer is that right yeah and what
what's your reason there because it
seems like they um oh I guess that's
just to get the the overall temperature
up right yeah it's a little bit late to
be honest I would rather play something
like this a bit earlier but the right
here the the whole premise of me winning
the game is that the temperature is
going to be close so I have to do
whatever I can to just get a smart seat
production right now that's right yeah
so that's actually a really interesting
thing going on here it's it's uh so I
know that I'm gonna start the next
Generation so my first thought is like
all right what I want is to play this
beam from an ethereum asteroid and then
I can pick up the terraforma Milestone
and maybe just also the thermalist at
the start of the Next Generation I can
like abuse this because I'm starting the
Next Generation oh that's cool so
there's even a deeper layer going on
here because what I'm realizing is that
the the oxygen is about to close
so even though I'm in a good position
around the table right now I I'll start
the next Generation there's still some
stuff here I consider yeah so right here
I'm picking up uh actually the Milestone
and also thermalists so um I was like
you're you're solidly ahead there yeah I
could have done that at the start of the
Next Generation but the other layer that
I'm talking about is that the oxygen is
about to close so if I'm not getting
something out of the oxygen at the start
of the Next Generation I'm I'm not gonna
get those TR right there so it's what
I'm losing by doing it like this is I'm
losing like three heat and three energy
because I'm not playing
team from a thorum asteroid this
generation but what I'm getting is
potentially two
um
TR on the on the oxygen scale so this is
way better that's way more important
um so so this is why I'm doing it like
this
I personally I love the idea of the
milestones in the awards where they're
sort of nominated and everybody benefits
from it but I mean you only want to
nominate the ones that you're you're
going to win so it's kind of neat to
divert your income to something that you
know could potentially benefit everybody
and might actually benefit your
opponents more than you if you misplay
it yeah yeah I think this award here it
only costs eight and um at this point
I'm the only one going for for heat
production that's right I think I end up
like getting second place in this one
but this is like entirely my own fault
or it's actually a conscious choice that
I end up making because I calculated the
last generation that I I could actually
make another play
um we will talk about that in the last
generation but there's a lot of math in
the last generation of this game it's uh
yeah no kidding
so when you're you're just doing the
math here while we're we're looking at
the card selections obviously protected
habitat is like the best one of the best
cards I could pick up right now because
what this does it is allows me to
actually put down the greenery using
steel and I have a bunch of Steel I have
nine steel so this is perfect and on top
of that I can also place it in a way so
I get one more plan so I can just make
one more Greenery so this is why the
play in the last generation ended up
really
um it was a hit-up play and it really
ended up helping me here because now I
will get the last two available Tira on
the oxygen scale thanks to the choices I
made in the last generation
oh really so that's what I'm doing right
now I'm
already got the Milestone that's out of
the way otherwise if I didn't do it like
this the other guy could have claimed
the Builder Milestone he was really
close to it but by doing this way
playing it safe or or what you would
call it now I can get the last two
um yeah available here on the oxygen and
on top of that I get to use my plan so
now I'm I'm immune to like asteroids and
stuff like this so this is what's really
good for me man yeah that oxygen just
blasted out of there I really thought it
was going to be the final one to close
yeah uh it's really hard to predict
sometimes I think the reason I thought I
I'm about I'm it's probably not going to
be the last one is because I've in just
seven or eight Generations I'm already
like pumping that up with like seven
just because of the steel works so uh
usually like this it's it's uh it's not
gonna be oxygen that's the last one to
close wow you've hit 40 points here
while everybody else is still in the 20s
yeah that's pretty cool it's a little
bit misleading still because then you
also have to take into account I only
have one VP and if you look at like red
I think red has like a histasis and
there's a lot of cities in this game so
he's just gonna right have a bunch of
Mega credit production and probably a
lot more VP than me so it's uh I feel
good at this point but I'm not so sure
I'm gonna win it if I win it it's
because it's gonna be close at seven or
eight Generations
um well if it goes to nine there's a
there's a good chance that one of the
guys could take over
take me over here very cool do you play
this game socially or is it mostly
online uh mostly socially over the board
actually uh yeah but I I also played
like a lot on the on the app just for
just for uh relax but it's like a
perfect game when you have your laptop
in your bed and you're like going to
sleep I'm just gonna take one game
before going to sleep it's like
I'm too lazy to actually play this game
on my on my I'm a tower I'm a big
computer but yeah it's a perfect game
for a laptop that's awesome yeah it's
interesting because uh games like this I
tend to cheat with the opening rules
where you know instead of drawing two
corporations and choosing one uh when
I'm playing with friends it'll be just
take whoever you want right do you ever
do it that way or do you always stick to
the rules there I will do a little bit
different actually but mostly when I
play with my friends we have like a
bunch of us on my content and I have a
lot of that stuff so I have like maybe
40 or 50 corporations so so we have like
only one rule that we do differently and
that one rule is instead of getting two
corporations we just pick four
corporations or with that pick we get
randomly four corporations and then the
first thing we do is we have to like
discount two of them immediately so we
have two corporations and then we get to
see the rest of our preludes and our
project cuts
um gotcha okay
all right here
um if you notice I I just saw AI Central
and no anti-gravity technology and you
might be thinking oh why didn't I pick
up that but the a cute little trick you
can do you could just go to the awards
and look at the scientists uh instead of
actually checking everyone out so by
doing it this way I was like all right
nobody is actually having any science
text this game so this is not a problem
um so I'm not even gonna Mass converter
I just kept that because the two other
cards were unplayable so I'm not
actually I'm not gonna keep Mass
converter and once again Luna beam here
uh
I think this is another
uh it's a little bit greedy I understand
why I do it the reasoning why I keep
this card is because it has to
um heat production into energy
production and I did start the
thermalist so it's kind of like a card
that could help me to to protect this
award that I played but on the other
hand it's uh this is Generation seven I
want this video when generation eight so
it's uh it's not worth it I should have
rather spent 14 Mega credits just like
actually making one temperature instead
of this Luna beam
okay going to a standard price is this
the first time you've used a standard
project
yeah it's just a the thing is now I have
six uh plan production
um so even though the oxygen has been
maxed um it it I still can get some
points from cities and that's one
particular City spot here that looks
kind of Juicy just between there yeah
yeah you've got it you've got two to
start with and yeah and the once again
this is like a play that will allow me
to get some VP so once again if I just
want to close the game as soon as
possible this is maybe not the best idea
but in this case I just if you if you
notice I I didn't really have any good
cards I could play this generation all
of it was like well my hand was kind of
useless so I had like two two choices
either I could just start making
um
what's it called the asteroid standard
project to actually try to close the
game or I could just get one city here
just so I have something to place my
greeneries because I do have six plant
production six plants so
and the other city I have up north uh I
think I'll I'll end up giving
um maybe a little bit too many points to
my opponents if I if I plant my my my
stuff there so do you ever buy cards
just as a sort of a strategic plan not
knowing if you'll actually need them or
not but you just want to give yourself
options down the road or is that just a
waste of money
um
um are you talking about cops that I
will maybe play later or maybe that's
right where it caught it cost you three
in order to potentially you know it's
kind of like in poker when you uh you
take out you hope for something down the
road but you may not get it yeah I'm a
gambler at heart so I've I've been
guilty and like especially in Greedy
games picking up like anti-gravity
technology even though I only have like
ball science Tags I'm like I'll I'll get
the last three it'll happen it'll happen
right yeah
doesn't happen nah in this game here one
of the cards
um that could go into that idea would be
this physics complex I just played
um because the thing is like
if if I didn't do this I would have
another six energy for the Next
Generation but like I said it is Four
Points by doing it this generation and
then I can also use the action in this
next Generation so I think it's still
okay it will it will give me like four
BP for this card but it is a card I
picked up rather early in this game so
it's I was definitely not sure if that
was the right way to do it
which of your uh yeah which of these
opponents would you say is the biggest
threat now and why is a person
cooperation I would say it's red but
it's not the I noticed in this game that
he's not playing well the other two uh
are good players they're like
consistingly slow playing consisting
milestones and stuff like this right and
also consisting bonuses especially right
what he's gonna do he's gonna yeah yeah
I hate to say this but no he's not he's
not a good player because if I recall
he's actually gonna help me close the
game now and that's like the opposite of
what he should be doing
um but the other two uh the other two
are pretty good
so I think probably green but it's hard
to say green yeah maybe white in the
purple I can't remember but one of those
are probably my closest rival what are
their main strategies then
um well I think one of them is uh E coli
so if you look at the map here he
already has like a fair amount of points
on the map
and if I check them out or check them
out sometimes you you can you all you do
is just click on your opponents to see
what they are actually doing do they
have a lot of VP do they have a lot of
plan production what what are how are
they gonna make their point this game
in terms of Milestone and awards I think
it's pretty even in this game so this is
not really a big consideration I think
we go each got one uh so I got I got to
watch for sure and and yeah it's pretty
much a wash and then there's the awards
over there
um I'll check them out I'm I'm 100
certain that I cannot get any of these
uh
remaining Awards so I I I'm not even
thinking about it anymore I just thought
all right I got my thermalist I got my
one Milestone that's it that's good
enough yep you're just hoping you have
enough of a cushion with your your VP
sir yeah yeah it's your TR
and I think I think I will yeah it's I
feel pretty good at this point um it's a
it's quite okay
so yeah physics complex here
doesn't look like we're quite gonna
finish in gen 8.
uh
I think uh if you look at me oh this is
like I'm I'm not even slow playing oh
okay there we go but someone actually
yeah this is what I mean well who did
this purple Oh I thought it was yeah
actually both purple and green no both
purple and red actually helped me to to
close the game so
they're of course also helping
themselves they want the TR and stuff
but it's uh it's definitely in my
interest that they're helping me to
close the game like this but I actually
had a plan to I I believe I could have
closed the game even without their
health because if you notice I haven't
even I haven't even done anything yet I
still have 57 gold so I was just
planning to to maybe spend my eight heat
and just make a bunch of asteroids
yeah you're waiting to see what they're
doing in order to find a way to maximize
your efficiency then yeah yeah you could
say that so right here it looks a bit
strange that I'm actually spending uh
using an asteroid instead of oh I'm
getting another city okay yeah so so
this city play it wouldn't have been
possible if my opponents would have
actually
uh prolong the game or if if they hadn't
like turned up the heat like this then
there's no way I would build the city
but right now I have a lot of making
credits left over because they are kind
of helping me so this is uh this is uh
it allows me to make this play and the
city is going to be worth maybe three
points so
it's still questionable but there's also
the fact that it's right next to water
it's giving me a plant here so
it's not bad at all
it's right here
oh yeah what I was saying before is uh
my choices here is now to close with the
heat with the eight heat cubes I have
where I can close with the asteroid or I
can like hope one of my opponents are
closing the game or I could
um I could just spin my cards but the
what I'm really calculating here I'm
gonna yeah now I'm looking at the awards
here what I'm really calculating is um
if I spent my eight heat I will concede
my first place on the thermalist but it
might be worth it because what I can do
instead is I can get this man Groove
down plus the trees and those two by
themselves would give me enough uh
places on the map to actually get a
second place in the landlord so even
though I'm losing the first place on
this on the thermal list I get to like
get more points this way because I'm I'm
getting a second place in the landlord
so there's a lot of stuff too this is
like one of the more complicated last
Generations I've had because there's so
many upgrades yeah there's a juicy place
for some Greenery there between two of
your cities right yeah that one I'll
give for sure
um and and with the trees yeah of course
I'm also calculating how many how many
plants I will need to actually get
another Greenery so right now I could
get six plus six so that's one more and
if I get the trees I can get actually
two more plants in the upcoming
generation so I kind of want to place
both of these cards
but uh right now I'm missing one goal if
I do it like that okay I think that's uh
that's because there's no place where I
can actually uh place the uh
The Mangrove and get like an adjacency
bonus to water so I'm I'm like missing
one gold here and it's really awkward
so I think what I do I find a way around
this I can't remember but I think what I
could do yeah now I'm looking at the
landlord you're really struggling to
find something yeah there's got to be
something here yeah and then of course
that's also my my Omni Corporation
special power so I still haven't used
that one yet
okay so we're moving into the end game
here uh tell me what you're thinking
about here
yeah here there's a lot of math going on
uh like I talked about so uh what I kind
of want to do is I want to play the last
two hands and my cards in my hand
Mangrove and also trees but I'm
beginning to realize I can only play one
of these and because I also want to use
my omnipower and also want to close the
game so um if I close the game with my
heat like I said it's uh I'm gonna lose
the first place on the um
on the thermalist but on the other hand
if I do that uh I I will have more gold
so in this case I can play one of my
cards
um so I can get the second place on the
landlord and it's uh there's a lot of
like if I remember correctly I'm like
losing I I just need one more goal I
needed one more goal to play both of my
cards and I also needed one more gold to
play
um I think one of my cards and 14 to
close the game with a standard project
and the three for umni so it's a
it's it's really close but it comes back
to the few mistakes I made in this game
it really adds up in the last iteration
here I just needed one or two more gold
than I could have made a better play but
it's uh oh that's that's painful yeah
that's a little bit painful so right now
what I'm debating is should I go for
Mangrove or should I go for trees and I
think it's like guitar shop I think both
of them is going to give me one point on
the card well both of them is gonna give
me one point on the
uh additional Greenery I can make
actually two points if I so I think I do
go for trees yeah just because the trees
can actually go next to my city so so
that would be the only difference
between those two cards at this point
um
because I I just calculate how many
planes I need to to make an extra
Greenery index around so I'm still like
thinking about should I really forfeit
this first place in order to play trees
and I I'm giving up like what is three
points but then I'm I'm also getting
some points back to get the I'm getting
two points from the landlord and then I
uh of course the play itself the green
array can make here is like worth two
points and also there's one point on the
card so when you put all of this math
together it's a little bit better just
to close the game using the the last
Heat the last eight Heat
yeah I'm looking at people's heat
production and stuff like this right now
I'm at 15 in thermalist and the other
guys at 14 because like I said he's uh
he's uh unfortunately the other two are
good but this guy is not that good but
uh maybe he forgot about the thermalist
because I believe he actually spent some
heat at this generation so that's a bad
on his part because not only is he
helping me to close the game but he's
also like giving me the thermalist well
hopefully he can watch this video and
destroy you next time around yeah
probably
no he wouldn't need to to watch this
video to do that he's probably fine
um and also yeah so
the thing is with the if I give up this
uh this this the thermalist I think did
I do it now no not yet I'm still looking
at the other guys like I must am I then
gonna get the second place on thermalist
if I spent the date heat or what's
happening here right I noticed you
didn't use standard projects very much
at all
no it's uh I think uh if the other
players didn't actually terraform so
much heat in in heat in this lapse
generation I definitely would have I had
like 57
Mega credits or something and I think
all of those were like dedicated to
actually just pumping asteroids in the
last generation right if they hadn't
helped me so my plan was to just
actually close the game with standard
project asteroids just because it's very
important for me my cards are bad and my
like strategy is to close the game here
at eight or as soon as possible it ended
up being eight because of the
the lack of heat production around the
table and because of my own choices I
also went a little bit greedy picked up
some some VP along the way
um
Jenny looks like it's going to be a done
deal here right so yeah for sure and now
I am using my my eight heat to actually
close the game so I'm forfeiting the
thermalist but like I said it's worth it
because it allows me to play trees which
allows me to get a second place on the
landlord so that's a lot of this this
was really complicated this last
generation actually it's funny yeah
what's the shortest game you've ever
played in terms of uh generation
I think generation six it's a it's the
shortest I've played yeah okay in the
longest
or the longest uh I think only only for
the memes I've had like one game go to
15 but other than that I've had quite a
few games to go to 14 if I like both me
it's only two player games to be fair
but if me and the other guy is like
having a lot of fun with like our greedy
engines and stuff it can go to 14 but it
doesn't happen very often okay so this
is definitely on the low end
yeah
but the in five player games uh it was
it was in a tournament actually I played
in real life it went to only sixth
generation I was like it's almost not no
fun because it feels like it's very
random who's gonna win these Ultra short
games it's like you don't really have a
lot of lot to say because you can't
really
of course there's a lot of things you
can do to to maximize your chances but
it's a when it only goes to five or six
or or maybe Seven Generations it's it's
a little bit more out of your hands if
that makes sense right yeah
[Music]
it's always tense oh that's it solid
finish there yeah so green was my
closest rival yeah okay yeah it actually
with all of the uh the greenerycats yeah
yeah
yeah so the big three parties he's he's
getting seven points on me but I'm still
beating him because I'm so far ahead and
terraforming rating yeah and Greener
recent cities is pretty close it's uh I
was not no yeah yeah I guess yeah it's
pretty close
wow purple really didn't care about the
greenery
[Music]
no it's uh but the
I think red could have had a very good
chance of playing this game if he'd been
more experienced because he was playing
classes and there was like a lot of a
lot of cities being made in this game
and he should have more uh he had like
what did he have to
did you only get like two victory points
for cities and three for greeneries this
is right it seemed like insane for a
thousand player that is right yep two
for City three for Greenery yep yeah oh
well yeah
it's a you know maybe he's just having
having some fun maybe he's distracting
watching TV I'm not gonna be too hard on
him but he was he was playing for the
awards he got seven there so
yeah that's true yeah so he he comes
with lots of metals and ribbons so
that's great well thank you so much for
the run through appreciate that and we
will check out your 279 uh point game
which will uh show how to build an
engine so thank you so much for your
time
a problem
remember get out there get gaming be
legendary
[Music]